I knew there had to be something so I
may have mine told me about it
I couldn't believe it I thought the name
is a bit weird
I was like Nathan real is this place
and then I went and I had this
absolutely amazing time it was basically
a whole evening about why people get
together with certain people in
relationships and I loved how everyone
talked and shared and learn that stuff
it was like the best kind of chat mixed
with the best ever lecture I belong so
much stuff I can never have gone near
without it you can basically take
classes in just about anything love
money sex friendships politics
philosophy you name it they've got it
and then put this really cute little
shop with gorgeous clothes and books and
other stuff you've got this amazing
website full of fascinating articles and
I've even started seeing a therapist
they've got in-house there which is just
about the biggest tree to ever give
myself an hour to talk to someone who's
trained about the other things going on
my mom
people often say we live in this shallow
materialistic culture where no one ever
wants to talk about the real stuff but
it's not true
you just have to know where to look and
I found it
you